and you've just bought a property
in newcastle
we're doing a video we have an audience
the popo are watching to check we're not
saying anything wrong
so should we have a little look around
at this property that you've just bought
let's go i'm coming in
now the police are in the area the house
looks really rough
is this area
bad
no it's not actually are you sure
we are very close to the city center we
have a near article four area
oh okay
yeah yeah oh okay okay what does that
mean what does that mean near article
four area
so basically that's that's areas where
you can't actually just buy
a normal property and convert it to an
ah so if it's in an article four area
you can't turn it into a hmo but you've
just bought on the edge of article four
which means that you can so what's this
what's this space going to be
this space is going to be the first
bedroom that you get into the property
and we are planning to put the annual
suite here as you can see it's a high
ceiling property is quite big property
so it give us all the chances to
transform it and create a nice living
spaces for our clients fantastic how
much will this room
rent out for once it's got an ensuite
and once it's in really nice condition
with the ensuite around 400 425 about
445 so this is gonna be a bedroom but
you've got plenty more bedrooms in the
house as well so show us around
[Music]
so what's all this area going to be down
here another bit another bedroom no this
isn't going to be a bedroom the kitchen
is quite small through here so what the
plan is we're going to get rid of this
get rid of this wall
cut all the way down here we've got
plans of the arctic construction
engineering is going to be fine it's
going to be a nice open plan making the
most of the space we've got nice
open-plan kitchen area please when all
the guys can hang out so this is going
to be a communal space a communal area
with a communal kitchen with extra size
fantastic so that's one bedroom
downstairs let's have a look upstairs
can literally see the very foundations
of the house
i'm not sure whether i'm more scared of
falling through the floor or something
landing on my head
but
definitely got your work out folks
so what's in here then
this is going to be a double bedroom
it's quite a nice size um
yeah this should rent out 375 to 400
pound per pound a month okay and we can
get a little cheeky view right here of
the outside
looks like you're gonna need a skip
pretty soon yeah so so this room as well
i mean this is a big old house
andrew you mentioned that you never had
the money to invest in property but you
have always had about 20 30 grand saved
away
tell me about that 20 30 grand
it's like your safe place
it is yeah all my life ever since i was
18 19 year old i've always kept money in
the bank thinking i'm going to be safe
everything's going to be all right for
the rest of my life but the reality was
if i keep the money in the bank i'm
going to have to work for the rest of my
life right i took the leap mbp bank
account and my joint venture with this
lovely lady julian and we're going to go
through the figures shortly of the joint
venture and what that looks like but
congratulations in pulling the money out
do you feel how does it feel to have
nothing in the bank exciting i feel like
i'm alive really when i've learned when
i had money in the bank i felt safe but
i was existing now that i've got in the
property i've stepped up my comfort zone
the money's went to work yes now i'm
alive and i'm excited but i personally
think money is safer in bricks and
mortar than it is in the bank because
in the bank you're not getting a return
on investment your money's shrinking
whereas we know that in newcastle
properties are only going to be going up
especially if we win the football later
on today
guess what cap
we lost
you need to be sure all right so what's
through here then another bedroom come
on jillian
so as you can see this is a very big
bedroom wow very big
it has double windows it's quite big
space we are going to put two ensuites
here and one the one that is going to be
in this corner is going to be the
ensuite for
that is going to be for this bedroom and
still the space is going to be massive
so it's still going to leave enough for
a double bed so you're going to end up
with two double bedrooms upstairs both
with ensuites and ensuite room
downstairs this room is what has got
fabulous views it's really close to
newcastle center the views are fabulous
you can't quite see
from this angle
i mean can you get this window open yeah
we have a little look sir
hello
look how wonderful the people in the
street look
look at this dude look at him
1-101
fabulous views
so the center is that way
the views are that way
and the community is this way
don't be filming me
how can i help you
what is going on upstairs then we've got
some more bedrooms
now i can't lie
this feels a little bit difficult to get
around i mean if jillian's gonna have to
duck then that that's that's bad a bad
sign yeah so what's gonna happen here
andrew what are you doing with this bit
yeah so obviously the head clearance
isn't great and as you can see if you
come up here the roof is boring really
bad a little bit of moisture i got in
yeah um so the plan is we're going to
build a dormer
it's going to take it all the way out a
little bit further to that beam there so
it's going to be a lot more head
clearance obviously when we apply for
the hmo license we're going to need to
make sure they use their head clearances
there so that that's what the doormat
will offer us and your architects looked
it over oh we've had the structural
engineers in we're all plans are in
place
now these rooms what is the plan where
are these guys going to go to the toilet
it's going to be downstairs
and
yes these are going to share a bathroom
okay ducks
here we are planning to
put a nice desk area so people can work
there when they were from home okay so a
desk here
and then you've got a room a room so all
together in total that's three ensuite
rooms but five rooms in total with two
of the housemates having to share a
bathroom
yeah
and the bathroom
is going to be put
down right here
i mean you could potentially i know
we've talked about the possibility of
putting two
small off-suite rooms
which we potentially could do it's space
permitting but this is definitely a good
size to put a big bathroom where the
house match can share
there's a property over the road there
looks like it's gonna get boarded up
yeah boarding what does that mean it
means it could be potentially for sale
are you guys selling this is this house
being sold you know
all right
again it's just building relationships
with the right people on this main road
the top which leads into newcastle
there's quite a few hmo management
companies yeah i've went in grab coffees
with them had conversations with them
give me little areas in the refurb how
much are you thinking how are the quotes
coming out andrew for the house
we're looking at between 30 to 30 to 35
but obviously it's property when you're
going you've got to have your
contingency we're looking at around the
40 thousand pound mark but the deal
stacks what's the plan once you've done
the work to it we're going to refinance
it pull out as much money as we can and
get it rented out and then get on the
next project and also where did you get
the money for the refurb again goes back
to what samuel teaches it's a people
business um i rang a friend down in the
midlands hadn't supported him in a while
just wanted to see how he was doing and
he asked what i've been doing and i just
told him i said i was looking for a kind
of well i was trying to raise finance
for the uh for the refurb um and he said
look i've got money there let's let's go
so i'm getting money off him we're gonna
give him you know like a 10 return on
the money that he lands and hopefully
build a nice relationship with him how
much will he rent out for in total once
it's all done fully fully talented about
two thousand pound a month about two
thousand pounds a month amazing great
job so let's have a little look at the
back of the house it's really important
to look at the exterior as well as the
interior because you don't know whether
you might need things like a new roof
where there might be structural problems
have you guys had a structural survey
yes yeah
so it's nothing wrong with the actual
house it's nothing to concern us but it
was recommended to change the roof and
make that dome at the back of the house
so then we have the head clearance that
is required for the application this is
the straight
you can see when you look at a roof
you can usually see if the roof needs
fixing just by looking at it
so we're going to get to the roof is it
just this one here right
okey-dokes
so you can see i mean it doesn't pick up
super well on the on the camera you can
see how the roof kind of bows
yeah it doesn't look straight you can
also see there are some um tiles some
some slate that's missing and i'm not a
roof expert by any stretch of the
imagination but you can kind of tell
that this roof needs fixing so what's
that sit in your back about five grand
five thousand eight hundred five
thousand energy for a new roof fantastic
how how long did it take since doing the
training because you did the deal
selling masterclass the deal selling
masterclass is more about how to package
and sell deals you found this but you
just keep it how long did it how long
did it take to find it and then to
complete on it and get the keys we found
the property
within about 24 hours really quick um
we've got the keys two and a half to
three weeks it was that fast that is
just quick big energy
he
understand very well about repossessions
and he guide us through the process he
he was absolutely fantastic and it took
us three weeks we thought we exchanged
in two weeks and then we completed in
three weeks i mean andrew you've shown
the power of being able to bring other
investors in you don't need your money
you can bring all the people in um what
have been the key lessons of this so far
um but almost at the start it was too
good to be true but when you actually
get into the truck into the live
training and you're seeing things
happening in front of the eyes you can't
unsee things yeah um totally
life-changing i'm still at the start of
the journey
being the best investment in training do
the training do the training once even
absolutely i think one of the things
with your training is that you teach us
how to do things alongside so it's the
practical side and the theory inside and
that makes you push yourself further
during the training make the phone call
look for properties and straight away
with you there and all that and having
all the mentors around during the
training to help you if you feel like
you are stuck with something and that is
unavailable so amazing he's been amazing
well super proud of you guys uh we're
going to be documenting the journey so
expect to see this roof change soon and
another video and also you're going to
see their full interview once they've
become financially free on winners on a
wednesday
subscribe smash like and we'll see you
guys soon
i'm nice with the flow
just like the demeanor
i'm feeding my fam
i'm feeding the meter they got the iron
while i got the steamer